[Music]
we're continuing our monthly
collaboration with my friends that learn
Liberty this week my guest is head of
education at the Institute for Economic
Affairs in London as well as a historian
and lecturer and he flew all the way
across the pond to be here dr. Steve
Davies welcome to the show
thank you very much glad to be here I
heard you got held up by President Obama
so we did we just got told that a VIP
was going through the airport and so
they had just shut it down for half now
so we were held up I guess it must have
been really important yeah after an 11
and a half hour flight you don't even
want to hear that it's the President or
there's nobody really that no absolutely
yes yeah so alright there's so much that
I want to do with you and I watched a
ton of your learn Liberty video so I'm
I'm pretty well-versed in in some of the
stuff that you're well versed in first
did you want to come to America just one
more time before our election well
absolutely there's something really
strange going on here in the United
States I think it's a although maybe not
that strange because I actually think
that what's happening with Donald Trump
is past a more widespread phenomenon in
most Western democracies which is the
rise of a kind of politics that's
commonly described I think misleadingly
as right-wing populism and what it
actually is is a politics that combines
left-of-centre economics strong support
for the welfare state with an extremely
unpleasant kind of nativism anti global
ism nationalism and that's pretty much
where Donald Trump is coming from it's
straightforward Hamiltonian economic
nationalism combined with the very
unpleasant kind of identity politics I
would say yeah but he's not alone he's
part of a much bigger phenomenon
okay so let's unpack a couple of those
phrases there so you'd say this isn't a
right-wing phenomenon because his
politics are kind of our kind of length
right and that it's that but he is using
nationalism so that that is more of the
right side what what were the other
parts though well there's also support
for the welfare state support on a
strictly national basis I mean the
correct name for this kind of politics I
think is nationalist collectivism you
could call it national socialism but
that kind of been claimed already that
may be a little too scary to scare you
it's nationalist collectivism basically
and it's on the rise across most Western
democracies a few exceptions like Spain
Portugal
Island but otherwise this is the kind of
politics that we see on the rise
everywhere I'm afraid marine lepen in
France get builders in the Netherlands
Donald Trump here pretty much everywhere
Canada's another exception so what is
happening globally that is cause that
this isn't just the finish I mean I
think everyone in America thinks
everything's about us all the time and
this is just our phenomenon it has
nothing to do with anything else but
what's happening was well there are two
things I think one of them is that a lot
of the support for this kind of politics
comes from older working-class voters in
what you would call the Rust Belt
decayed X industrial areas where life
has not been good for quite a long time
and these people feel that they're
ignored by the political establishment
that the system is not working in their
interests and that kicking back yeah
that's one reason and some of that you
think you would argue is legit yeah it's
legitimate yeah deed that they're quite
right you know life has been pretty hard
for them for quite a long time yeah the
other thing though which I actually
think is more important is its to do
with the politics of identity it's to do
with a feeling that a certain kind of
identities under threat from the process
of globalization cosmopolitanism maybe
political correctness a whole bunch of
stuff like that so there's a very
powerful cultural reaction a reassertion
of a certain kind of identity and I
think that is what is really potent and
really driving this kind of politics so
how much of that is just a reaction to
some of the stuff happening on the left
that's you know I come from the left so
that's the part that I've been focusing
on and I do see a certain element of the
rise of Trump and the political
correctness stuff and you know the
social justice warrior stuff I see it as
a natural reaction to what has happened
on the left or maybe and maybe in Europe
it's more because of the immigration
that you know these people marine lepen
for example yeah I think both there is
no truth in both of those things
actually undoubtedly the push button
issue as we saw in the brexit referendum
in the UK for example and with Mary
indepen is immigration particularly
immigration from the Middle East but
also from other parts of the world as
well
but that in a way is not so much because
of a regression per se is because the
way in which large-scale movement of
people is seen to be transforming and
changing the nature of a settled and
established national community and now I
think that in terms particularly United
States yes there is quite a lot of
pushback
the kind of social justice warrior as
you've eluded to PC politics on the left
and in particular the politics of
identity if you're going to push a
politics of identity where apparently
the only group who aren't allowed to
have an identity are white working-class
men yeah sooner or later those kind of
people are gonna say well hold on a
minute you know I have this identity to
which you are not respecting to your own
term so there's a lot of pushback coming
on I think that shows how really the
response that liberals need to have and
I would include many people on the left
in that category should be one way you
were certainly importance of
individualism and of identity as being
something that to a great degree is
personally chosen and formed rather than
being something that's given to you and
fixed in some way yeah I mean I love
that and that's exactly how my own
evolution has sort of happened over the
last couple years coming out of
progressivism which is more about the
collective to ultimately realize I would
only want to be judged by my own
thoughts and my own actions so let's
circle back a little bit to Europe and
then we'll do our election that we'll
get in some big stuff so when it comes
to the immigration situation all over
Europe I sense what you're saying is
there's a certain natural reaction to
people coming in and not assimilating
properly or whatever else there may be
the economic strains and all that stuff
what what is the proper solution for all
these countries now because it's the
cats out of the bag Laurie right well
actually a lot of the response is
misguided in my view because for example
there was a widespread perception
feeling that immigration imposes costs
on the countries that the immigrants go
to all of the research shows that
actually this is not the case immigrants
are a stream of good news because
typically they are younger than the host
population they are almost always in
work they've come to look for work they
want to do productive labor how can that
be a problem you might say and so
typically they are taxpayers rather than
tax consumers they typically make a net
contribution to the budget they do not
depress wages because typically they do
work that the indigenous population
either can't or won't do used because
they lack the skill set they do have a
marginal depressing effect on the wages
of the bottom 10% of the income range
but that's about it but there's a
widespread misconception or
misunderstanding of what the economics
of immigration is actually about and
that's a failure of public education
real
so that's part of it I think the more
profound thing though is a feeling that
there's a threat to an established
indigenous culture and I think the
response here is to simply be more
confident you know I have enormous
confidence in the assimilative power of
the culture of a free society and I
think the thing to do is not to say okay
here are people who are asserting a
particular collective cultural identity
what we need to do is assert our own one
in response to that and aggressively
against that first one the thing to do
is to emphasize individualism and the
degree to which a modern free society is
one where people are free to form their
and shape their own identity through the
choices that they make and that should
be true for everybody right so in a way
you're looking at it in sort of the the
macro sense of how we should deal with
all this a certain amount of the people
on the ground they just don't see it
that way they see well where are these
people coming in even if the job thing
is incorrect they feel that their jobs
are maintained so when I when I read
stories about things like in Germany
that I saw something that it was gonna
cost 1.4 billion euros to give the
refugees or the migrants dental care I
mean these things are just not true
basically or actually it's nice and true
the if you look at the areas where there
are problems these are all areas where
it's the state that is involved or is a
major provider you do not see grocery
stores panicking because they suddenly
have to find food products and other
products for new customers on the
contrary they look at it as a business
opportunity the private sector
everywhere actually sees large-scale
movement of people as being as I say an
opportunity not a problem
it's the areas where the state is
involved that you find problems and what
that shows us is actually the
incompetence and inefficiency of modern
governments as compared to the private
sector so even if we viewed everyone as
as the individual we're gonna talk a lot
about the individual here do you think
there's possibly something different
with this wave of immigration especially
related to terrorism and we know that
there's a certain amount of people that
Isis wants to infiltrate it out and
cross borders that there is something
different about this because even if all
of us in the West say it's about
individualism and let's judge people
individually and by the
their actions and all those things if a
certain amount of people don't want to
assimilate yeah there's what what do you
do then well in in in one sense not
assimilating is not in and of itself a
problem where I live in Manchester
there's a well-established Jewish
community been there since the 1880s
1890's these people are Hasidic Jews
right very strict ultra-orthodox a lot
of them are liver which is actually and
they're not assimilated in some sense is
taught they never watch television for
example against their beliefs and so on
but nobody I think would regard that as
a problem my point of view just means
I've got a wonderful bakery named Eric
bagels right the problem is as you say
the association of a certain category of
migrants on the Middle East with Islamic
terrorism now what's the best way to
respond to that that is a difficult
issue aren't my own view very much is
that the the ultimate solution is to try
and sort out that complete mess that the
Middle East has become but in the short
term essentially this is a policing
problem what you definitely don't want
to think about is dealing with this is a
problem of military security it's
essentially a law enforcement problem
right so as someone that doesn't love
state power does it make you nervous
that you have to sort of give a certain
amount of state power to the police or
to the border controls or whatever to
actually make sure that they're doing
the right job yes I am nervous about
that and what I would say by the way is
that the kind of increase in state
surveillance which has been put through
in the United Kingdom for example by our
current prime minister when she was in a
previous job as Home Secretary was
actually counterproductive in that
regard because basically if you think
about the tests the security services of
God they're looking for the proverbial
needle in a haystack
so if that's the case why do you then
make the haystack even bigger by
intercepting virtually everybody's email
that actually makes that job more
difficult not easier yeah and so I think
that actually what really you need is
good old-fashioned undercover
intelligence work which means
penetrating organisations identifying
key people you basically try and keep an
eye on and good old-fashioned spy work
really it's all always going to work but
that's the way to do it
so it's interesting because you're
making a real argument for limited
government and yes slim trim government
through through a prism that a lot of
people don't think of it they think we
need big
vermin to protect us from Ewings and and
have surveillance and all these things
the people that are for it but you're
really making an argument for if you
actually took a lot of that away it
might be a more efficient way ability it
would be much more effective in my view
that's really interesting so let's let's
talk about Briggs in a little you know
cuz I did a little bit of it on this
show and you know I'm constantly talking
about how our American media doesn't
give us much of anything so we didn't
hear about it at all then two days
before everybody was freaking out about
it we saw it on Twitter then it happened
and we don't talk about it again I am so
for people that have no idea what
happened can you just give me a little
history of it and then we're at okay
Britain's relationship with the European
Union has always been I think a bit
fraught and difficult it's been like one
of those unhappy marriages if you will
where Outsiders wonder why are those two
the reason being that British
politicians and the British public ever
since we first joined the European eco
communities that then was in 1973 have
always seen it's been basically about
economics it's all about getting
economic advantage on the continent ever
they've been equally clear right since
the Messina conference in 1954 but this
is all about building a political union
so they see this part of the kind of
grand political project and the British
politicians always say they don't really
mean it these Continentals this is just
rhetoric which of course is actually
quite offensive and surprisingly the
Continentals get a bit irritated by this
attitude so essentially there's a
growing mismatch between what the
British public think the EU should be
and the actual nature of that project
and that's got significantly worse since
the Maastricht Treaty so it caused all
kinds of internal political ructions and
David Cameron in what I had to say was a
grotesque asking mr. act of mr.
judgement from his own perspective
called a referendum to try and sort out
his internal politics now in that
referendum everyone thought the
expectation was that the status quo
would win I'm saying I expected that so
that's basically why he called it
because he was empowered I figured I'll
call it they'll agree with me and
that'll sort out my party problem that's
that yeah okay because generally
speaking referenda normally go for the
status quo right and in this case the
overwhelming majority of members of
parliament
most of the respected pundits most
economists virtually all of the big
business firms that were asked
the Bank of England pretty much any
authority figure you care to mention
said yes you need to vote remain so what
took place is a popular insurgency and
in which the ordinary British public
thought well no we don't agree with this
and they basically went against the
advice of the bulk of the political
media business leadership now the vote
that came together to vote leave if you
will was basically a coalition of three
quite distinct groups I think on the one
hand you had what you might call brexit
Shire older conservative voters
typically middle-class slightly older
living in the countryside living in the
affluent suburbs yeah and that's one
block so that's a little bit of the
people that you described voting for
Trump a little bit but slightly more
moderate the second group however all at
the people who voted for Trump this is
older white working-class voters in the
traditional labour heartlands of the
northeast of England the Midlands
Yorkshire the vote in some constituents
is they're like Sunderland which is
arrogant of say scranton/wilkes-barre
that was sixty nine percent vote for
leave an absolute landslide and that was
it was that block of what you might call
populist voters working-class voters
that put leave over the third baseball
group which I belong to yeah here's what
you might call radical classical
liberals who very small group but again
you could say we made the difference in
some ways because what we wanted to us
to be able to have a greater range of
options for the British government by
being outside the year use controls and
constraints so there's those three
blocks of people that voted for leave
basically yeah I like radical classical
liberals because I've been saying
classical liberals it sounds too too
benign or something radical has a little
something extra there so okay so when it
was happening and you you don't say you
you were part of this did you expect the
vote to go that way no because as you're
saying the entire establishment was
saying don't do it it's not gonna happen
and the polls were showing it wasn't
gonna happen no I always thought it was
going to be tight but my own expectation
was it was going to be about 51%
remained to 49% leave because normally
in referenda like this the undecided
voters who make up their mind at the
last minute split two-to-one for the
status quo
now I actually think they did here but
what happened was that the poles D
underestimated the liebe share of the
vote by about five percent the reason
being a lot of the people who voted
leave with people who did not normally
vote and pollsters always discount
people who say that they don't vote so
they got their sampling wrong and how
they underestimated the the share of the
vote that leaves going to get so looping
this back to Trump because I see such
parallels here
I suspect the exact same thing is gonna
happen I'm not saying Trump's gonna win
but I do suspect there's a depression in
the polls because a certain amount of
his supporters either aren't being
polled for whatever they're in places
that they're not polling or they don't
want they don't want to be publicly
shamed or admit it or something like
that so I sense that what you're talking
about here this groundswell of support
that was not spoken of I suspect that's
happening right now do you think that's
fair I do think so I think there's two
things going on there one is what what
since we're here in Los Angeles is known
as the Tom Bradley effect where people
are not honest in the answers they give
to the pollsters but also I think that
actually the pollster samples are
probably slightly wrong they're probably
not counting the correct number of Trump
voters because one of the things he did
during the primaries was to bring a
record number of people into the primary
process who had never voted before now
what I suspect that means is he's going
to be much more competitive than he
currently appears to be in states like
Ohio Pennsylvania maybe even Michigan
and Arizona where I think there's a
significant number of people who have
not voted before who will vote yeah what
do you make up will you see Nigel Faraj
come here and speak at Trump rallies
what do you make of the connection
between the two of them and and is this
really you know if when I click on it
Infowars link or some of the other
things the more right things Breitbart
that really they're fighting the
globalists the globalists are coming
here I think there's some degree to a
one-world government thing that's trying
to formulate but like how much it feels
so conspiratorial well I that that's
exactly the kind of alignment that I was
talking about these but both Nigel
Farage and you keep in the UK Donald
Trump here they're part of the
nationalist reaction against the
increased kozma policies and
globalization that we've seen in the
last twenty to thirty years
our feeling that there's transnational
organizations that are pushing an agenda
they don't like but basically it's more
a kind of localism a hostility to
cosmopolitanism and to globalism and you
see that on both sides the atlantic now
that's a politics I strongly reject but
you can't deny the reality and the
existence of it yeah and that's what
makes it so hard to talk about because
it's not fun to talk about something you
reject but you know to be honest to be a
classical liberal you have to
acknowledge that something's happening
which is absolutely strange it's no
point in ignoring this I mean if you
disagree with something with a belief
that a lot of people have the thing to
do is to engage with it what you have to
do is to actually talk to these people
respect their views but show them that
you think they are mistaken and here's
why they're mistaken yeah okay so now
Briggs it happens yeah everyone said the
next day the markets are gonna crash the
economy is going to crash everything
will be over we're gonna be fighting for
bread all right have you had Bradley no
no no more with that no problem I think
we're still the phony wall stage right
now I think that's going to be an
enormous and quite serious political row
in the United Kingdom the next few
months the big question now is okay what
do we do and there are really two routes
that the British government can take
quite simply to simplify it one is they
can go for what's a membership of what's
called the European Economic Area which
means that we would be a bit like Norway
now that means we would have access to
the European single market regime but we
would still be bound by a lot of EU
regulations while no longer having any
say in how what they were or how they
were formed
so that's sort of like that's sort of
like staying in the you but light
exactly
exactly and the the thing the other
alternative is to say well we don't want
to do that we basically want to
negotiate a free trade deal with the EU
the trouble is that once tourism a
triggers what's called article 50 of the
Lisbon Treaty which is the withdrawal
process it's got a strict two-year limit
and it's not clear that you can
negotiate a two-year at free trade deal
in just two years
so that would throw us back upon just
membership of the World Trade
Organization which means that would then
be a six and a half percent tariff
between Britain and Europe now that's
probably more than compensated for by
the decline in the value of the pound
that's taken place but it's still not
not very welcome now the critical
political thing is the City of London
seven percent of British GDP would lose
its pass porting rights you
would not be able to do euro denominated
business unless we're in the European
Economic Area the problem politically
from Teresa may in the government is
that the Europeans have been very
reasonably in my view saying look if you
have become member of the ei you have to
accept free movement of labor that's
part of the deal
you don't cherry-pick your conditions
which seems perfectly reasonable to me
and the problem is that for political
reasons because so many of the people
who voted leave did so on
anti-immigration grounds
she is not all of them as a significant
portion of them sure she's not prepared
to do that and so the result is that
therefore it looks like we're going to
actually not apply to join the EEA
effectively and that's going to cause
enormous political ructions now in the
longer term I think the British economy
will do fine there may be some some that
though we some losers probably the City
of London there will be some gain as
though manufacturers in particular and
then exporters consumers because the
price of a lot of goods like food will
go down it'll even out its bit of a wash
really but in the short term it's going
to be quite a lot of political fireworks
so all that being said aren't those
subtle reasons that brags it was
actually the right decision because you
guys still have to sort of negotiate
things with the EU in a weird way that
allow them to have power over you and
that was what the whole purpose of
leaving was so in a way it's like better
to do it now than 10 years when a lot of
this stuff has even been time something
right absolutely
I mean the point is what brexit does and
this was my main reason for voting for I
wasn't a passionate leaver
but I did vote leave in the end the main
reasons for doing it is that it
increases the range of political
possibilities open to the British
electorate and the British government
for both good and bad right now they're
highly constrained because a whole lot
of radical policies on both left and
right would fall foul of the EU zone
rules and regulation so there's actually
a narrow range of what is allowable
politically now that we have left the EU
or once we've left the you you it
becomes much wider a whole range of
options are opened up now the job for me
then is to argue for the right wants to
be really bad ones right your did your
job just start it's not exactly yes but
that's so that's my main reason for
doing it I think there are much greater
options open to us now in the future
yeah do you sense that you as a entity
is real
in trouble I mean everything beyond what
just happened with them with you guys I
mean they've got Greece basically in a
hostage situation right I mean is that
am I being - no that's a hyperbolic
Greeks will agree with them but yeah I
mean so what do you think the future
here is you have you have you know
Britain leaving
you've got Greece in a hostage situation
I mean ultimately the borders that are
crumbling people aren't happy with well
the real problem that the EU faces is
the incredible act of hubris they did at
the Maastricht Treaty which is to create
a single currency when they don't have a
single government now interestingly
pretty much every economist on the
planet at the time regardless of their
politics said that this was a really bad
idea and they all thought it was a bad
idea for the same reason which is that
there's no historical case ever of a
single currency area that doesn't have a
single government surviving and that if
you do have a single currency area in
countries that are not economically
aligned if you will and you don't have a
single government all kinds of really
bad stuff happens Paul Krugman and
Milton Friedman in the same way made
almost exactly the same point that now
they ignore the advice from all the
economists and as Paul Krugman rather
wittily put it the good news is we know
now the optimum currency area theory is
completely correct the bad news is we've
had to bugger up the economy of a
continent to figure it out figured out
you prove it so the point is they still
haven't resolved that problem now Greece
is a small country they can handle
Greece
what if Italy goes under which is quite
likely the Italian banking system is in
really really bad shape if there's a
major crisis in Italy or maybe in France
or some other larger country they won't
be able to resolve it so they're going
to have to either create something like
a government for the eurozone or they're
going to have to allow the euro to be
dismantled and I drew those is a huge
event plus there's an election next
spring in France and there's a pretty
reasonable chance that marine lepen will
win the election yeah if she's up
against one candidate from a
center-right Alain juppé she will lose
if she's up against the former president
Nicolas Sarkozy the polls show it's very
very close and I would actually tip her
to beat him right because that could be
one of the situations where the polls
are going to wrong exactly her plus also
these polls now before camp
she's a very effective campaigner yeah
and so I think she could well beat the
rival candidate if it's Sarkozy now if
she became president I mean the odds are
still against that but if she did she
said she'd immediately call a referendum
on France leaving the EU now all the
polls there indicates 65% of the French
public would vote leave now if that
happens the EU is finished that's it's
done for yea it's done for so it's in
really bad it's in a very tricky
situation right now the EU so for
someone like yourself again classical
liberal and you want this to be about
the individuals so I can understand the
separation why you think ultimately this
is good it seems like in a weird way you
then have to align yourself with the
marilla pens with the you know you end
up by default falling into a category
with the people that want to leave them
with the Nationalists streak but that I
don't sense that you have no so how does
it how do you negotiate that with
yourself with great difficulty this is
the big problem the problem for many
classical liberals in the UK was if we
vote leave will this not give a big
boost to precisely the kind of politics
that you most dislike that was the
argument to some of my colleagues for
example yeah
I think that basically you have to
realize if things like this happen you
are going to be alongside a bunch of
people that otherwise you totally detest
and what you then have to do is to argue
the case very very strongly against them
now the crucial thing here I think is
for liberals both left and right if you
well classical liberals and social it
rules to come together and to realize
that they have a common foes if you will
in the shape of the National
collectivists and on the other hand the
radical radical left and so here in the
United States for example I think is
quite likely that there may well be a
kind of proportional in the next few
years between the kind of moderate part
of the Republican Party so-called which
is actually many ways the more
libertarian part fiscally conservative
but socially liberal if you will and on
the other hand the mainstream of the
Democrats and this will be aimed at both
the kind of people who are now voting
for Trump and also the kind of people
who were supporting Bernie Sanders
earlier on in the primary yeah so I know
this is this political realignment is
one of the things you've been talking
about lately and I love that because
that's exactly what I've been trying to
talk about that I no longer as a
a liberal I don't really see
conservatives as my enemy as maybe five
years ago I might have thought that they
would be where now it's like yeah we can
have some disagreements about taxes and
maybe we're not in the exact place
related to abortion or a series of US
states rights or whatever but there has
to be a new center developing here
otherwise a lot of classical liberals
will end up going this you know the
libertarians will end up going further
to the right classical liberals may go
further their left that's not good for
any well indeed I mean the way to think
of it is this I think since about the
1970s the big argument in politics on
both sides of the Atlantic but
particularly here in the US has been
between one group of people who are
economically interventionist nogales
Aryan but socially liberal versus
another group for a pro free-market but
socially and culturally conservative
that's been the big division what I
think we're now moving towards is a
situation where the divide is between
one group of people who are broadly
free-market broadly individualist
globalist perhaps a bit more egalitarian
than classical liberals would like but
broadly liberal versus another group
which is the national collectivist I
mentioned earlier who are actually
economically interventionist Pro welfare
state but very culturally conservative
quite authoritarian anti-globalist anti
cosmopolitan and that's the new division
I think we're seeing in politics
everywhere and what that means is that
all a lot of the existing subgroups are
going to split up so conservatives like
I don't have to decide well okay what is
more important to you the cultural
conservatism right nationalism or the
free markets and the individualism and
if you're on the left you have two sides
well okay what am I really more
interested in and if you're one of the
kind of identitarian anti-globalist life
you actually may find yourself thinking
well actually right now I've probably
got more in common in some ways with
this kind of new emerging Hamiltonian
nationalist politics if on the other
hand you really value individual liberty
and globalism openness the rest of world
then you're going to find yourself
making alliances with these other people
who were forming your opponents so I
think there's kind of big shuffling on
the deck going on in most Western
democracies so as a historian well can
you think of another time where we had
such a maybe not on a global scale
because we're so connecting now but
where you saw just these real fractures
happening no you know in real time like
when's the last time you saw something
else is it well done
it happened in the UK certainly was in
the 1960's and 1970's and I think
something like that happened over here
in the United States as well where you
had this sudden reversal where the South
went from being solidly democratic where
you know if you found two Republican
votes are counted by muster twice right
to the situation we have now where the
south is solidly Republican and you know
the Democrats who become the party of
the North entirely that kind of switch
took place then in the 60s and 70s
similarly in the UK back in the 1890s
here in the United States with William
Jennings Bryan the cross of gold and the
famous you know Democratic convention in
1896 when the populist basically took
over the Democratic Party major change
in the nature of the Democratic Party
landslide victory Republicans again big
realignment of votes and interests in
the states then so this kind of thing
has happened before it's not
unprecedented yeah but what do you add
about the global element where now it's
like we're so connected we're all on
Twitter we're all watching TV and on the
internet and that these things are
happening at once and that we're a
hundred years ago if something happened
across the pond it mattered but we
didn't know about it for a while
versus now it's all happening in real
time this is true I mean there were more
connections than you might imagine
in the 19th century God as you might say
too much slower so now there is much
more a global phenomenon in fact what is
interesting is the very few countries
where this kind of realignment isn't
happening Canada is one not happened
there so far
Spain is another Japan but generally
speaking you can see the same thing
happening everywhere and I think what
happens is that what now because we're
so interconnected what happens in one
part of the world tends to feed into
what's happening elsewhere
hence the great interest that Donald
Trump and his supporters have shown in
brexit and Nigel Faraj coming over here
and making all these talks that would
not have happened 100 years ago I don't
think that would have had a book I don't
think that would have happened ten years
ago when I saw Nigel Farage out there at
this rally I thought this is really
unprecedented the last time that a that
a leader from another country even an
out you know an ally whatever does it
doesn't matter came and with supporting
the opposition presidential candidate I
thought this is probably is true it's a
function of no cheaper air travel and
things like Twitter and the Internet
you
[Music]